in creating an immersive story why do
you focus on audience before you focus
on the characters in the world
I think that when we think about
immersive storytelling we always go back
to the idea of
you know the the person the audience
member who's coming into committing
their time
and energy into the space how do we
create an experience for them that is
truly immersive
and in any other type of Storytelling it
is about another person's story it's
another character going on their own
Journey having this adventure
but an immersive storytelling the hero
the protagonist is your audience member
is your visitor they're the ones who
want to commit this time to going on a
journey that is
for them that is unique to them that's
personal to them perhaps
um and so when we think about creating
an immersive storytelling world or
experience it is a multi-dimensional
video game come to life
this player if you will is going into
this experience and into this world to
do something to experience something and
so we create a story and a narrative and
a world around them and they are the
um the first person perspective of
looking around
um you know a space an environment and a
world we see it through their eyes and
so you know when I think about
any type of experience that I build I
always think that I am guest zero you
know I I want to uh create a world and a
story where I am
the visitor that is experiencing this
for the first time and how do I really
put myself in their shoes and see things
through their eyes and experience things
through the way that they would
experience it because when we have the
first guest the first visitor who comes
in they should be aligned with you know
the experience that
I and the team have created in order to
create something that is truly truly
compelling and engaging and we want to
surprise people and we want to make sure
that we engage with them in a way that
really
opens up their minds you know shakes
them up or makes them think about and
see the world in a different way
um whatever your goal is in your
experience you really really have to
consider
what they're experiencing through their
eyes and through their perspective in
order to feel that this is an you know
an experience that is emotionally
engaging and meaningful and I think that
it's so important to think about it from
their perspective
because they are the hero of your story
they are the protagonist so how do you
create a journey and an adventure an
experience that is about them
um so it's a very very daunting task
because maybe one person's perspective
or
um experience of a place can be
different from another person who
experiences the same thing and that's
completely fine because no two human
beings are alike but how do you create a
world a story a place that really makes
them feel something that perhaps
transforms them because that's something
as storytellers and creators we want to
do is we want to transform people we
want to change them in a positive way in
in a way that opens up their minds
broaden their Horizons
um allows them to explore and play and
engage and discover in ways that they
never thought they would you know maybe
there are even experiences that makes
them feel more like themselves than they
would normally feel in their ordinary
lives you know we hear about people who
um you know have an avatar that's of a
different gender or plays a role that
they don't normally play in their real
lives and in perhaps in this experience
they can truly feel
more themselves than they've ever been
and so the the role of the Storyteller
so important
to be able to allow for that platform
that for that world to exist for people
to truly
feel like
um
they belong that they connect that they
can understand the world around them in
a way that feels very meaningful and
purposeful to them
how does the Storyteller know where
their audience is
that's a really good question I think
that
sometimes you don't always know
um I think that if you are working on a
particular story
um that's you know popular knowledge or
you know of Pop Culture you know who
your fandom is your target audience is
but if you're working on a story for a
museum or a larger General audience I
think that
as much as possible you want to be
inclusive of everyone
and I think that you really want to
maybe research in terms of like the
market that you're in uh who's most
likely going to attend your experience
but also knowing your age group as well
is this an experience for children is
this an experience for teenagers is this
an experience for adults or for everyone
and it's extremely challenging to try to
please everyone but
you want to make sure depending on your
experience you want to make sure that it
is inclusive of everyone so that they
feel like they can belong in your story
World
um and if it isn't appropriate for a
younger audience or for a particular
group of people then that's something
that you need to communicate beforehand
you know that's something that you want
to make sure that your audience's
expectations of the experience is what
they think it is so I think that it
really depends on who you're trying to
reach out to and whether or not
um
that truly is your audience sometimes
can be surprising
um sometimes it doesn't necessarily you
know what you expect to be your you know
maybe your the majority of your audience
members might it might not turn out to
be that way and you're going to be more
appealing for the younger audience or
whoever it is right like I think that it
just it depends on your experience for
sure
and the audience will surprise you
sometimes you think they're going to
love one thing and it turns out they
actually hate it or they love something
that you never even considered yeah and
and a lot of the times in
you know in this industry you make
changes you adapt right if something
doesn't work out if something isn't you
know built to the expectation of the
audience how can you improve upon it and
how how can you change it how can you
make some amends so that it is something
that they were hoping to experience
something that is more compelling and I
think when you think about designing
your experience you want to keep in mind
that there could that you should be
flexible in that you should think about
um how if you needed to make a change
it's not going to be so time consuming
or costly to your project can you find
ways in which it can be classic and
Evergreen are there ways that it could
be a an easy way for you to switch out
you know a character or an element of a
story whatever it is so that it always
feels relevant and current
um and um you know something that is
always
me that feels new to people so it really
yeah it really depends I think on um
the subject matter and also you know how
you
what you're trying to accomplish in the
first place like really understanding
what the goal of that experience is and
um
yeah knowing who your audience is
who are streakers strollers and students
oh okay so this is a a term that was
coined
um a few decades ago by a museum
educator and uh especially in the Museum
Industry there's the the streakers the
strollers the students are also
sometimes called the streakers the
strollers the scholars
um Street if you think about going to a
museum the streakers are the ones who
just kind of want to walk through all of
the galleries all of the rooms and just
get a glimpse of everything
um quickly and the strollers are the
ones who you know they'll take time to
meander through all the galleries maybe
stop at a particular painting or a piece
of art and really enjoy it before they
move on to the next object and the
scholars or the students are the ones
who want to absorb everything about that
particular piece of work or every single
piece of work in the museum
so as a museum designer or an
experienced Creator you want to think
about all of those different levels of
Engagement if you will
and how do you create an experience that
is appealing to all of them
um there could be you know I see
examples in museums where they have like
just a short description or a title of a
painting and the artist and
um if you want to read further you can
there's more information and if you want
to dive even deeper maybe you'll listen
to a podcast or the audio tour or you go
on one of the tours with one of the
guides right so having that
different options for your visitors to
engage with whatever level that feels
comfortable to them that makes them feel
like they you know got their uh um but
their value for coming to visit your
experience is a really great way to
think about how you want to create
um an experience that will appeal to all
those levels of um participants and you
know there's other ways that people
think about it it's you know in a
fictional world it's levels of fandom
um and some people like to think about
it as like you know uh what's it's the
the waiters the swimmers and the divers
is also another way that people talk
about you know how deeply they want to
immerse themselves in a story a world or
a topic and so it's uh it's really good
to keep that in the back of your mind
when you're creating a place because if
it is uh an experience that's designed
for young children let's say then maybe
it is more about
um the very you know the the streakers
or the waiters right they they just want
to get a sense of everything just a
little bit of here and there and they're
not going to be reading every single
plaque on the wall or anything like that
they're going to move on to the other
thing
but if you're creating an experience
that perhaps is historical or
biographical
then you want to make sure that you are
being a hundred percent
um accurate and fair and responsible in
sharing that story with the world so
it's an extremely big responsibility as
a Creator and a Storyteller to think
about all those different levels of
Engagement and how they can participate
in your story and your world